for people
who uh are trying to get better at chess
beginners or um at any stage of their
development what advice would you give
about getting better
Except watch yeah of course watch my
videos check out chastity.com that's
where we're going to scale the courses
too
uh uh but no on a serious note you have
to be prepared to lose way more than win
my mom gave me advice when I was
maybe 13 or 14 and I just discovered
that I I liked girls
she said you're gonna get a lot more
no's in life than yeses
uh that even happened with with my wife
actually our whole journey is is quite
quite fascinating just paved with
rejection okay paved with yes very
various uh ghostings uh over the course
of years but then we got married and we
love each other very much so
um so it's a it's a wonderful Tale But
it's the it's the same in chess You're
Gonna Lose a lot and you have to be for
adults I noticed kids and adults learn
chess very differently kids yell out in
class and they're very excited and they
don't realize how many times they get
something wrong adults never want to
talk during lessons because they're
afraid of being wrong adults will
preface correct answers with this is
probably wrong but like shut up you're
paying for a for a private lesson this
is the place to be wrong you know so
adults especially think that being
dominant in a career where they've
dedicated a lot of their brain power a
lot of their work ethic and a lot of
their study time it's going to translate
to chess they do it to keep their own
kids they helicopter their own kids
because they try to apply a lot of the
same stuff
studying chess is different than
studying anything else anything else
same could be argued for martial arts I
guess but yeah 100 you have to have a
beginner's mind and what that actually
means is
sucking in every aspect of the game and
and studying all the interesting ways in
which you suck and you will realize you
get better without actually trying to
get better I show up to the boxing gym
one day I move my hips better yeah and
my I'll do Shadow Boxing uh Sensei goes
you're moving your feed better today you
got better I'm like I didn't practice
footwork it's just your brain just
starts putting it all together randomly
you might study a shitload and still
lose 100 points if you're gonna study
chess oh and for [ __ ] sake this is the
only activity where people go in going
how much do I have to work to be a
Grandmaster nowhere else in my life have
I ever seen someone try to pick up a
hobby and want to be the the top ranking
level only in chess
you're right but like for example when I
like grappling Sports I'll see people
come to a gym and basically ask like how
long before I can get into the UFC right
but UFC champion is different I mean no
Grandmaster is equivalent to be getting
into the UFC
um I guess yeah so but people quickly
realize when like the 110 pound girl
Taps them out over and over and they're
a 230 pound like
um ripped dude they realize like okay
this is an art this is a journey yeah
and I think if you resist the lessons
that failure teaches you that's when you
don't grow so like just relax and one of
the things you have to learn probably
place the chest to is to know how to
relax your body your mind
and just like
there's something about just like you
said like
if you don't resist it if you relax
then your body your mind will learn the
way of this game
[Music]
and probably add to that is just put a
lot of hours in of having fun
but then then I I on that Perpetual
chess podcast I listened to somebody
that say like it doesn't like Puzzles
none of that what matters is the number
of hours you spend kind of suffering
meaning like thinking deeply like count
like like straining like thinking with
your mind like really working hard so uh
and then you know you have the Magnus
who says no what matters is the number
of hours you spend having fun
yeah it's a mix it's a mix he's right I
don't quite agree with suffering but I
think people do a lot of fake learning
they play Speed games they
just go through tactics so okay I have
to do 20 tactics okay Boop wrong next
one I used to tell my students you need
to do
10 puzzles and you need to get 100
correct I don't care how long it takes
so I suppose that kind of is like the
suffering Theory
but if you do 30 puzzles and you get
eight correct
what even is that that's
so laughable and the correct amount of
you know was it 29 I don't know but 26
it's you can't do that you have to get
things right and that's the only way
you're actually and that requires like
thinking deeply like really struggling
like especially if you're doing the
puzzles at the level that that's your
level I've done a puzzle for an hour
before because I was so stubborn yeah I
didn't want to just put in a wrong
answer yeah the the the guy was
listening to said like that's good you
should you should do that maybe for me
and the same with blindfold shows I have
to say like my blindfold skills I never
practice I just I can visualize the
board quite well I've played
than most I've played four games
blindfolded at the same time that sucks
that just feels horrible in the brain
afterward but like I can play Four
simultaneous games apply for it yeah
what's that take to do that I don't know
and I get asked that all the time how do
I practice why the [ __ ]
should do that to your sister good party
trick it is yes I it is the video of
Magnus doing it in Columbus Circle on
YouTube has like I don't know how many
views
I did it live with an announcer I can't
imagine how chaotic that was but he yeah
it's a great party trick yeah oh there
is a Reddit thing I I forgot to ask
Magnus that they asked me to ask him
because they moved the wrong piece yes
and then somehow he remembered I don't
know how that happened I have to tell
you I
I was I kind of presumed that he figured
out
from the way the other person was moving
that they moved the wrong piece yeah